Catholic Church is in a state of
upheaval tonight a newly released letter
by a former Vatican ambassador to the
u.s. Carlo Vigo no claims that Pope
Francis and other top officials of the
church knew of the allegations of sexual
abuse against Cardinal Theodore
McCarrick the Archbishop of Washington
they knew it for years what's the real
story here for more we're joined by
Raymond Arroyo managing editor of EWTN
news who's covered the Vatican for
decades and a fox news contributor
Raymond who are these Wars the main who
is the main whistle well Archbishop
Vigano who you mentioned earlier he was
the new CEO the ambassador to the u.s.
for the Vatican here for about five
years he also ran all of the ambassadors
our embassies around the world for the
vadik yeah Larissa four very
well-respected man of integrity a
sharpshooter and a man who has been a
whistleblower in the past
in 2011 he wrote secret letters to pope
benedict at the time outing corruption
in the vatican those were leaked and
became the vatileaks scandal it was his
expose z' meant only for the pope's eyes
that got worldwide attack why is he
releasing this letter well seventy-seven
years he claims he wants to unveil his
conscience he can't go to his death with
the information he has and he sees the
corruption and the double-dealing in the
Vatican he's exposing it his allegation
the principal one is that between 2009
and 2010
Pope Benedict imposed a penalty on
Archbishop mckarrick because he knew
they had paid settlement to men that he
had abused
he also took him out of public ministry
now when Pope Francis became Pope viga
no claims he informed the Pope himself
of mckarrick Smith's deeds and the Pope
ignored this and restored mckarrick
that's the charging allegation and some
others are watching for bigger nose yes
we should put up a full screen I want
people to see this this is a full screen
from the letter of vegan Oh read watch
this
it says Francis knew from at least June
of 20 23 2013 that mckarrick was a
serial predator in an extremely dramatic
moment for the universal church he must
acknowledge his mistakes and in keeping
with the proclaimed principle of zero
tolerance
Pope Francis must be the first to set a
good
example four Cardinals and bishops who
covered up forma Carrick's abuses and
resign along with all of them he's
calling for the Pope's resignation and
for all of these people says exploding
all oh yeah it's coming on that big
family meeting in Ireland which was not
well attended but here's the Pope
reacting to the news on a plane
returning from that family conference in
Ireland I read it and I will say
sincerely that I must say this to you
and all of you who are interested read
the document carefully and judge it for
yourselves I will not say one word on
this I think the statement speaks for
itself
well many Catholics are saying it speaks
for itself and they feel the Pope should
have done some disclaimer said something
it looks like an evasive answer and
makes the Pope look bad in the meantime
bishops around the United States and the
world Tyler Texas Arizona and the entire
Conference of Catholic Bishops say these
are credible charges that need full
investigation they're demanding that
from Pope Francis could this lead well
we'll see look there's no mechanism to
do that so we'll have to see we'll
continue on all right fantastic grandma
thanks so much